[Music]
let's go to kathy in topeka kansas
what's up kevi
hi dr john how are you i'm rocking on
how are you
really freaking nervous
ah don't be nervous hey can you talk
directly into the phone it sounds like
you're on speaker phone
i'm not on speaker uh there we go okay
now you're back
okay all right don't be nervous listen i
don't know what i'm doing either so
we're both making this up as we go so
you're good you're good okay we both
know that's not true so what's what's up
how can i help
um to stick to
what kelly told me to do
all of our lives are better when we just
do what kelly tells us to do okay that's
just it's a good rule of life i actually
have that tattooed on my forearm do what
kelly said
that's a good idea
um okay so basically um
the last seven years of my marriage
basically the whole time i've been
married has been a roller coaster and
kind of the same cycle of stuff
um which i know we'll dig into in a
minute but
the last few weeks some boundaries that
we have set
have been intentionally violated
and
i just
literally in the last 24 hours
um that cycle has shifted to the next
phase and now
um
i feel like i'm being too harsh or rigid
or unreasonable
um by demanding
dramatic change
so you're talking very cryptically about
cycles and things and roller coasters
and
ponies and dragons
like be specific
for seven years what has happened
has he been cheating on you is he an
addict is he abusive like for seven
years you've been dealing with what
like all of it um
so so he's been cheating on you for
seven years no not um not constantly no
and not
and not
so there was there was one affair that i
know for sure um and i know that he's
had other emotional affairs okay um
whether or not they're physical i don't
honestly know okay um he
a couple weeks before we got married
tells me that
bipolar disorder runs in his family okay
um and that's not surprising um he comes
from a line of alcoholics so
that has been so is he an alcoholic
sometimes when he will admit it but yes
okay
um he came uh about a year and a half or
so into our marriage two years in our
marriage he got actually in a
horrible motorcycle accident where he
almost died because he was under the
influence
um we've been married for seven years in
literally every year if not more often
like the first few years that he was
really drinking heavily um like we would
separate we've separated
separate physically separated like he's
moved out of the house twice
and we've been on the brink of divorce
every year
for
seven years
um so what has kept you together
um
every once in a while um
like when when we've separated we've
started to go to counseling okay
um so he has done that um a couple of
years ago he
started to look into
being
evaluated
for
um
depression
anxiety bipolar you know things like
that and he just kind of fell through
the cracks
um so you're doing a lot of talking
about him
i'm asking and i've done that too i'm
asking you
why have you stayed in this marriage
through an affair through an alcoholic
through what i
can only imagine is he doesn't come home
some nights through a couple of
separations where y'all said we gotta
get away from each other
why have you stayed in this marriage for
seven years
well after the first time it was
i knew that i
i didn't help the situation like i've
never been um i've never
been around an alcoholic in my life
um up until we got together so you
already you already dumped it back on
him i'm asking you
what
why
this is your life kathy this is your
life you are in the epicenter of your
life own it the good stuff and the ugly
stuff
what have you contributed that in your
mind do you feel like you've contributed
that meant you should stay that you
played a role in this thing so i gotta i
gotta i'm i'm sentenced to living in
this thing
i mean i guess i just knew that don't
guess don't guess just say it
it wasn't giving it my all like i wasn't
being patient i wasn't
doing everything that i could i knew
there were challenges within me
that i
language have you have you had an affair
have you cheated on him no no i have not
are you an alcoholic
no are you abusive
no
i
it can be condescending okay okay
um
[Music]
i can be a know-it-all okay
um
you know even just
a couple days ago like conversations
like
i can be i guess i can be i i can be
demanding okay um
you know i'm not always patient
so
over the last seven years would it be
fair to say that in some times
you've been more his mom than his wife
oh totally
totally
that's i mean and i've again that's
i've been in counseling off and on you
know for five years sure um trying not
to be that i know that i've taken
too much responsibility like looked at
what it because
when the arguments happen it's always
well you may he he will tell me well you
made me do this because you keep running
your mouth
and that's
that's a gaslighting nonsense and you
know that i know
i know and conversely
he's not making you do anything either
right now you know and i know i'm
oversimplifying this
right right
what i'm trying to get you to do is
these things get so tangled up
and you everything gets all wound up
together the good stuff and my guess is
when things are good they are
unbelievable
when you finally take off mom hat and
i'll even say when you're able to take
off your mom hat right somebody's got to
pay the bills and put food on the table
and make sure you're not living in a
pigs i get that and someone's gonna make
sure that idiot goes to work and
somebody's gotta hug that guy when he's
sick right right and vice versa when he
is on he's not using he is
probably
incredibly loving and committed right is
that fair
like right now in a day he's like it's
all puppy dog face there you go yeah
there you go i love you and i'm like but
that's right you weren't about the last
three weeks that's right that's right so
listen
these things get so tangled up and it's
hard to pull apart which part i own and
which part i just deal with and how much
of this is truthful and how much of this
is not and it just becomes a mess
right
and then it becomes well if he would
just fill in the blank and then he is
saying to himself well if she would just
fill in the blank and you get in this
this
someone's just got to stop the dance
you've heard me say that before
somebody's gotta stop the dance turn the
music off and just say what is happening
and these things go in these cycles
because the goods are so good
and we allow that to cloud over all the
bads
and
the bads can be so bad that we let them
cloud over the good stuff
and we just find ourselves stuck in this
this inactivity right we're just frozen
so something happened a couple of days
ago where you said enough is enough is
enough what was it
well we've so we've been um
we
started with a new counselor um about a
year ago okay and we set down some
pretty firm boundaries well in firm
boundaries um one of which is because
when he gets angry about
anything he
automatically is i'm gonna leave or i
want a divorce or
you know obviously because that's been
part of that cycle
and so um
you know for the last year everything
like we've been you know doing okay
working through
you know issues as they come up and that
sort of thing um
but three weeks ago
he got mad at something absolutely
ridiculous
um
you know we're trying to get the boat
back um
onto the trailer with my my oldest son
who is
20
and he
didn't do something right because it was
the second time on the boat and he
he got upset he was like well this is
why we never take it out this is i'm
just going to sell the thing you know
just starts going off so he has a temper
tantrum like a child
right okay and so i'm like all i said at
that moment was you know hey just calm
down
and
like just chill out and so when we got
home
and our child that we have together he
went inside
um
how old is that like
he's six okay
almost seven
and so
um he went inside
why are you mad at me because he's um
and it's funny because i literally just
heard you yesterday you know silence and
violence
silent treatment is like the thing
okay
and so he'd given me the silent
treatment and again that's one of those
things that we're trying to fix
and
um
i was like why are you mad at me and he
just goes off he's about how nobody
appreciates the luxuries that he pays
for because he owns his own business but
i mean he he does he's the hardest
working person i know i mean i can't get
him to stop working usually
because he's an addict
exactly he's addicted to that as much as
anything else but though so then we get
the wah wah wah what was me nobody
appreciates the right okay
and then he says
um he's obviously i'm gonna sell the
boat and i said okay sell it because
nobody
likes it when you turn into a bleep
every time we take it out
and
that was helpful good job right
i didn't i didn't claim it
it doesn't matter
exactly but you're like sweet a little
fire i'll throw some gas on it so you
threw gas and then what
and then he told me to pack my stuff and
get out okay so i
just kind of
and it did escalate a little bit more
but i just i stopped talking after that
point and then the next morning i
um
was making breakfast because you know we
go to church every sunday whatever and
so
i sent our son in to get him for
breakfast and he didn't come and so i
went in and i just kind of
plopped on the bed and pretended like
nothing happened
and
i said are you going to come eat
breakfast and he says
no i'll do it my dog son like i do
everything else and i'm like
okay so we're still there today
and i said
you know i was like did you mean what
you said because
we've promised each other this has been
a thing that we're not just gonna you
know throw this stuff around
yeah and she said he said well i wasn't
drunk and my blood sugar wasn't high so
yeah so here's the thing okay
this is the life you've chosen for
yourself
and it's not changing
right
and so at the end of the day you have to
have your or what statement
and more so for you you've got a
six-year-old little boy
absorbing this that this is how men
handle problems
this is how dads handle problems this is
what marriage relationships look like
this is what um how grown-ups act they
threaten each other
with
what i think is um
the worst thing you can do to somebody
which is to cut relationships that's
what get out means
right
right
that what you have done who you are so
bad
i am severing that relationship with you
and your son is absorbing this
as life this is how this works
and kathy this is how stuff rolls down
generation after generation after
generation
and for some reason
the roller coaster ride has been enough
for you to hang on there
and i'm not telling you to get out of
this thing
i'm not telling you to stay in this
thing
i'm telling you that you're getting the
life that you allow
and you are living the life that you
in the
that you are continuing
and if you've been going to counseling
for seven years with multiple different
counselors
and here we are seven years later and
your husband got frustrated trying to
put a boat on a trailer i've been there
it's the worst right it's the worst
but that was enough
to make him act like a five-year-old or
when he started act like a five-year-old
his wife said hey will you chill which
happens to me regularly and i have to
make a a uh um a decision
am i gonna double down on being an idiot
or am i gonna breathe and look at my son
who's wide-eyed staring at me and i'm
gonna say dude i'm sorry i know we're
trying to figure this out your dad's a
[ __ ]
or am i gonna
use silence as violence
and huff and puff and stand around my
house
does that make sense
sure this is the life
so the question you gotta ask yourself
is am i done with this or is this gonna
just be my life
and if it's just gonna be your life
let me let me say it this way you can't
change him
you can't you can only control you
that's it and it's scary and it's
frustrating and it's hard
if you're gonna stay
be all in when you stay
work hard on yourself do what you can do
in this situation
and if you are married to a guy who
rolls over every month and becomes a
bear
and choose
i'm avoiding him
or if you're gonna leave go
right now you've got one foot out and
one foot in
and so you are having this
wavering life your kid can't stand
firmly you're not standing firmly your
husband's not standing firmly
but i don't i consider threats
abusive
especially relational threats
i consider
ignoring somebody abusive
that
i consider that abusive
and so the abuse in your house has to
stop i consider when you
lob grenades back at him because you
know he's spun out and he's exhausted
and and and and you that's not cool
either
what your house desperately needs is a
big dose of grown-ups and neither of
y'all are acting like grown-ups
i'm not saying that uh you have you
you haven't earned it i mean it you it's
been a rough
go i get that
but that house is desperate people
acting like grown-ups
and they're just not
and so at the end of the day here's what
i'm telling you you can't control them
you can't you can only control you
threats are abusive silence can be
abusive
everybody's gotta start growing up
acting like grown-ups and you gotta deal
with you if you're gonna stay be all in
if you're gonna go go
don't be switzerland here on this one